hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
I'm going to be talking about stacked
imbalances okay and you know how it gets
misused by Traders but before we jump in
if you enjoy learning from my videos
don't forget to subscribe and click that
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new upload if you find today's video
helpful be sure to hit that like button
for me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway I love hearing your
feedback and oftentimes your feedback
gives me ideas for new videos to make
you know based off of your suggestions
so your sport really does go a long way
in helping me create content just like
this so let's go ahead and jump in
today's topic alright so imbalances
specifically I'll talk about spend some
time talking about stacked imbalances
okay because you know an imbalance
occurs because there's basically an
imbalance between the aggressive buying
and the aggressive selling so you have
um buying imbalances you have selling
imbalances and you know the question
does come up every once in a while what
is the optimal uh sort of percentage or
ratio in determining a buying a balance
or selling a balance so you can see here
right the red number in the footprint
right 42 against seven that is a selling
of balance whereas a blue number in the
volume in the footprint is a buying a
balance 14 against 66 5 against 24. now
you can adjust your imbalances in your
footprint chart if you're using my order
flows Trader software you would find it
up here imbalance trigger in percent we
actually have a another little setting
that's in my opinion equally as
important is minimum
imbalance volume and really what that
means is you can see the setting of 10.
so it needs at least 10 contracts traded
on the heavier side either the bid or
the offer for it to start calculating an
imbalance and just really quick just
show you why that's important because
you know sometimes you're going to have
volumes like this one against seven is
that uh imbalance well technically yes
it's one against seven but I like to
have a little bit more meat on the bones
you know if it was it's not showing up
as a imbalance the seven Lots because
it's less than ten okay and again
generally speaking in most markets
um it's not going to be a problem but
when you start looking at thinner
markets you know some of the grains seed
oils
um you know Meats again not everybody
really trades you know those other
contracts but you know for those type of
Traders
um it's going to be important or if
you're trading say um mnq or NQ or even
even ym
you know in the evening times you get a
lot of zero against five zero against
six zero against seven technically those
are imbalances but it's just not in my
opinion strong enough to um sort of
warrant and and imbalance right I like
to use that minimum volume threshold now
a stacked imbalance what that is it's
three or more imbalances stacked neatly
on top of each other so for example here
you've got three against uh 24 3 against
21 13 against 70. that is a stacked
selling a balance up here you've got a
stacked buying imbalance you got zero
against twelve zero against twelve zero
against fifteen five against thirty four
okay and
the the thing that makes stack solid
imbalances unique is it's very visual
because you have those three imbalances
one on top of each other
okay that hence the term stack now what
causes that well oftentimes it's it can
be a couple things right it could be a
big order going through the market maybe
somebody had
um you know 50 lots to buy or something
or 70 lots to buy so they just swept
through the market or they had you know
100 to sell so they swept down through
the market right here and here it could
be just like I said just a big order
sometimes it could be a stop right that
gets triggered you know maybe this was
like a little swing low here at 43.20
um you see the selling and balance
coming in right below that level at uh
4310 starting and it goes down maybe
there was a stop that got triggered
there but really you know at the end of
the day what it is it is a sign of
strong aggressive buying if it's a stack
buying a balance or strong aggressive
selling if it's a stack it's on a
balance okay now this is where you know
once you guys understand that this is
where it gets
um you know the Practical applications
of it how to use it in your trading
because because you know just because
you got a stack buying imbalance doesn't
mean oh I got to go ahead and start
getting long or if you see a stack
selling a balance here and here I got to
get short there's a lot of aggressive
selling coming in yeah there is
aggressive selling obviously you got
these imbalances that doesn't mean you
just Pile in immediately okay you
when you have a big order that's one
thing right big orders going through the
market
but you need follow through
okay you you want to see it continuation
right because again yes it's nice to
have a big buyer or a big seller coming
into the market
but once he's done is there any other
impetus in the market to give it a push
in that direction so just because I see
excuse me stack buying and balance
doesn't mean I'm going to just jump
right in right if I jumped into this
stack mining balance well it came right
back down and would have stopped me out
the selling of balance is over here okay
you know you see the follow through you
see more selling balances in the next
bar okay it goes down a little bit and
even get this other stack cell into
balance but it's just mostly going
sideways okay and
part of the your maturity as a Trader is
recognizing a market that's going
sideways now in the order flows Trader
software in in my software I have a
couple different ways three different
ways of looking at it one you could
identify the stack imbalance either
stack selling a balance or stack buying
a balance just directly in the bar like
this okay or
another way that a lot of our Traders
use it is to draw it out until tested
okay so you can see three right if I
wanted to make this cluster size bigger
right because I've got
um you know three imbalances technique
on top of each other if I want to make
it more stricter I could change it to
four even five but three is is fine for
most markets and most Traders change it
to until tested here okay so if you want
it
um
to be just in the bar itself all right
you change it to fixed imbalance Zone
size on the bottom to one okay but if I
want it until tested meaning that
there's a stack buying or selling a
balance in the bar
and then we immediately move away from
it right like right up there I see this
is stack selling a balance coming in
right we just made the high we're
selling off stack selling a balance
continuation in the next bar
I have this Zone here right one if I
know I have this Zone being drawn out
then it's telling me that hey you know
what this is a strong sign of balance
I've got some follow-through we're
staying below this Zone
that this is probably a strong imbalance
a strong stacked imbalance right you see
the market continued to sell off quite
nicely and again
take them in context of the market okay
we had just made a high of the day up
here now this was at two in the morning
and we're starting to sell off so we're
about you know two bucks lower off the
high okay but then we sold off from
44.70 you know we got all the way down
to 40s
um you know down here into 41s Etc so we
had a nice you know four dollar sell-off
from that high of the day now
another way that our Traders use stacked
imbalances right in terms of determining
is the Stacked imbalance worth taking is
if you were to use the fixed version of
the zone so let me just draw it out here
stacked in Balance right I'll change
that from until tested to fix and I'll
use five right now the reason I use five
I have a specific reason why I use five
um because it's starting at the bar with
the imbalance
stacked in balance and goes out so
that's bar one two three four five okay
what I have found is even if you're
trading back into the imbalance okay so
let's start with the stack selling of
balance and it's holding it's still you
know it's trained back in that's normal
to see
the market trade back into an imbalance
okay because really what you want to see
it come in and see more aggressive
selling
you're looking for the market to sell
off if it's on the other side of the
imbalance right like this one right
right in the next bar it's trading down
into the imbalance because it's a stack
buying a bounce right we should be
trading above it but we're trading below
it
we're definitely trading below it and
closing below it then that's a sign to
get out okay just as here right we have
a stack selling a balance so out of
these three one two three this is really
the only one that's that's kind of worth
taking right how some Traders would do
it is what they'll do is they'll they
have this imbalance they just drop a
limit order in there around you know
somewhere in the middle of the imbalance
wait for the market to trade back up in
there and give them a trade and there
you have a very tight stop just on the
other side of that imbalance right so
again
now this one and same with this one all
right you want to this is a selling a
balance right you're not going to get
short you're not going to drop a limit
in there when you're trading already
inside or just even in here what you'd
want to do right for this stack buying
imbalance you want the market to start
going up then you drop your bid inside
there not just immediately get long in
the next bar
at least here right it's traded down
okay then you can drop your offer inside
and again if we're closing on the other
side of this Zone
right either here here here or here
that's your sign to get out that's
probably not going to work right
obviously it just didn't work I just
eventually went up but
again you know what you want to do right
is you just drop in a bid in here right
you could buy anything here you got a
tight stop you know three four ticks
away okay you get stopped out okay you
get stopped out here
um this one you wouldn't take again if
you take this you know you're getting
short at 43 to move down to you know 41
you know down to 42 so you know you
could have a two to one
risk right if you're risking three to
maybe get six nine twelve
um it's up to you okay here another one
right stacks on a balance we're testing
it we're coming back inside
and then we sell off you know it's not a
massive sell-off but it's holding below
so that's how you can use these zones to
you know trade pullbacks into
selling imbalances now here you got to
stack buying a balance filed by a stack
selling a balance okay which is they
kind of neutralize each other in that
sense and we're just trading it inside
again it's not one that'll be looking to
get short in here because if I'm looking
to get short off of this staxon of
balance I'm looking for the market to
come off a little bit and then go inside
and test it
um see if there's anything else well
that was that one
that was from earlier
um
okay so I mean that's gold right if we
were to look at e-minis okay
so
again you know something like this yeah
you just drop in a buy-in here by limit
49 and three quarters okay comes down
here stops you out you try it again here
comes down here this is just unfortunate
right if you drop in your buy limit here
at 50 43.50 comes down to 49.50 that's
just three ticks and then it
goes up two points
um you know sort of same thing there but
here's a nice stack selling and balance
right we're trading below it which is
what you see see it's sort of come back
up testing and then sell off right so
when I see these things these stacks on
imbalances that are not retested into as
well to me those are great opportunities
here's another one
um here's one it pulled back right in
that bar this one
again sort of just pulled back right in
there
you know here we're pulling back into
the first level
okay
now so what is that
50 who knows if it got filled ideally
your ideal entry is going to be
somewhere here around 56 with the stop
just above okay so you lose a half a
tick half a point
but here you go right here's a nice
buying a balance that isn't retested in
the next bar if you're signed to get
long
it says this one is assigned to get
short but then you run into that stack
mine imbalance okay
here's a stack selling a balance but you
tested it right in that next bar I mean
it opened up here then shot up so we're
opening up below I guess you know the
point is as long as you open up the
lowest Axel and balance that's your sign
to drop in your offer
or
if you open above stack mine and balance
that's your sign to drop in your bid
there okay it's just unfortunate that it
just pulled back a little bit more
that's sort of the issue with trading
pullbacks right because if you're
trading a pullback
you know depending on how deep and
strong the pullback is it can pull back
just a little bit more
and then stop you out and then sort of
make a decent uh this is not a great
move but again if you're buying it in
here you know this is a four
level right one two
one two three or three levels
um if you're buying it in here at 70
you know you got your stop at what or 75
you know your stop is here at four and a
half it pulls back to four and a quarter
and then shoots up to you know 77 so
your two points is is gone you got
stopped out fine you know
that's how you keep your losses small
those are low risk entries right you're
literally just risking three ticks
you get stopped out right then you just
wait for the next opportunity to come
along okay
so there's different ways you can trade
them but
realize what is stacked and balances
it's a big order going through the
market and really what you want to see
is you know potentially a pullback into
it but if it's not the Market's not
reacting right if it's not pulling back
into that stacked imbalance that could
be your sign you want to go with that
move
so anyway guys I'll end that video on
stacked imbalances you know it's one of
the different ways that you can use
stacked imbalances so if you find these
uh videos useful and you know helpful in
your trading let me know and be sure to
subscribe to the channel hit that
notification Bell
so thanks so much for watching and being
a part of my order flow Community I'll
catch you guys on the next video bye bye
foreign